auf dem mond gibt es wo ich viel mehr
wasser als bisher gedacht die mengen
scheinin anteil sogar genauso gut wie im
erdmantel und hier auf der erde ist es
wahrscheinlich so viel wasser wie in
allen ozeanen zusammen also unmengen
wasser für zukünftige mondmissionen
bedeutet und warum die
entstehungsgeschichte des mondes
umgeschrieben werden muss jetzt wirklich
vom feinsten fiktion herzlich willkommen
2008 wurde zum ersten mal wasser auf dem
mond gefunden es vertragen es nur vor
ihren hier auf der erde also es wurde
hier auf der erde wasser auf dem hund
gefunden
wie bitte komplette verwirrung also 2008
fanden forscher und forscherinnen
tatsächlich hier auf der erde in
mondgestein dass die apollo mission mit
hierhin gebracht hatte wasser 2009 lief
die nasa dann eine alte zwei tonnen
schwere raketenstufe auf dem mond
aufschlagen und einen satelliten direkt
hinterher
die ergebnisse waren spektakulär dabei
wirbelten sie riesige mengen an staub
auf die dann untersucht worden
das ergebnis wasser und jetzt wurde es
noch mal getoppt es gibt nämlich viel
mehr wasser auf dem mond als bisher
gedacht dafür werteten ralf milliken von
der brown universität im kompetenz und
schweini von der universität von hawaii
daten der indischen mondsonde
chandrayaan-1 aus überall auf der
mondoberfläche gibt es demnach wasser
zitat wie wild über die oberfläche
verteilt was bedeutet dass der
wasserfront in den apollo proben keine
einmalige sache ist so million
vulkanisches aus wurfmaterial auf dem
mond scheint allgemein wasser reich zu
sein was nahe legt dafür den mann als
das lesen geht
das bedeutet aber dass die bisher
angenommene entstehungsgeschichte des
mondes so nicht stimmen kann man die
forscher
nach dieser theorie wäre der mond bei
der kollision der erde mit einem etwa
mars großen himmelskörper entstanden
dabei wäre aber das wasser komplett
verdampft das ergebnis der jetzigen
auswertung lässt aber darauf schließen
dass das so nicht stimmen kann auf jeden
fall ist es extrem rätselhaft woher
kommt das viele montags noch gibt es
dafür keinerlei erklärung nur eines ist
jetzt gewiss es dürfte für künftige
mondmissionen eine große bedeutung haben
es könnte nicht nur abwasser genutzt
werden
seine chemischen bestandteile könnten in
wasserstoff und sauerstoff zerlegt und
zu raten gas oder raketentreibstoff
umgewandelt werden eine erhebliche
erleichterung für zukünftige
mondmissionen sobald die pläne dafür
konkreter werden halten euch hier
natürlich auf dem laufenden
wollt ihr kein video verpacken über das
uns andere themen dann wollten wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke und hier geht es weiter
mit mondbasis nach internationaler
raumstation draufklicken wenn es euch
interessiert und ansonsten bis dahin
bleibt dran